To shade a diffuse surface, we need the cosine of the angle between the
direction to the light and the surface's normal. We can perform a vector
operation called the dot product to directly compute this cosine. First, you
must normalize the surface normal and the vector to the light. Normalizing means
rescaling a vector so that it has a length of 1. Normalized vectors are the norm
in reflection models. As we'll see, if a dot product of two normalized vectors
gives a value between negative 1 and 1, which will prove useful in computing the
effect of lighting. For example, say, I have the vector 3, negative 4, 0. To
normalize it, I find the length of the vector. This is simply the Pythagorean
theorem. Take each component of the vector and square it. 3 squared is 9,
negative 4 squared is 16, and 0 squared is 0. Take the square root of 25 and you
get the length of the vector, 5. It's lucky that turned out so easily. By
dividing the vector by its length, you get to normalize vector. So, 3, negative
4, 0 normalized is 0.6, negative 0.8, 0. Looking at this vector, it goes the
same direction, but only travels one unit. Note that normalizing a vector that's
already normalized leaves it unchanged. Try normalizing this vector again and
you'll find the length is 1. Dividing the vector by a length of 1, of course,
does nothing. It's very handy to normalize vectors in this way. Usually, we
store the surface normals as normalized vectors. We'll see exactly why in the
next lesson. For now, a quick quiz.